i have been made aware of a trailer on
netflix for a new dating show
that basically i think spells the end of
our society as
we know it the asteroid is coming
and if there's any justice under god we
will all
be gone soon that's that's what i i
think that's what i'm going to take away
from this
i want to get married i want to have
babies before i'm like 26 years health
insurance
welcome to the strangest blind date ever
hey how you doing damn how are you doing
could you fall in love with someone
based on
personality alone what is your ideal
woman personality for me is everything
ash first personality second okay can we
pause it there for a second um
so okay um what why
who but no
interspecies dating apparently is is now
a thing
also i like when they say no matter what
they look like but you may have noticed
that when people tend to evaluate
possible romantic interests they don't
just look at their head
their bodies are also part of this so if
you actually wanted to do
full-on blind dating what you would
actually do is you'd go back like one of
those 1970s show where people were
behind a curtain
or alternatively you could just have
them wear giant fat suits
and then we would see how all of this
went but as it turns out
like if you go back a little bit in the
trailer there are some people who are
flaunting
some natural body parts that um are
shall we say
not made up they're real and they're
spectacular right i mean like i feel
like you get a fairly
good idea that this person is not 300
pounds
for example so it's not like a full-on
blind date
also i think that if we're just
evaluating whether you should date
someone based on personality the mere
fact that they have now appeared on this
show means you should not do that that
is like the worst idea in the land the
only thing that you know about this
person
is that they are willing to get
themselves gussied up
in a bizarre halloween costume to go on
an attention-seeking dating show on
netflix
that right there means not marriage
material and anybody who's on the show
and thinks otherwise is delusional
this is just hideously stupid
in every respect other notes before we
go further
the attempt to completely divorce
biological attraction from dating
is a very strange one given the fact
that the left also suggests
that satisfaction of the sexual urge is
the height
of human existence that identity is
innately tied to your biological
and unchanging immutable sexual drives
but it's better if we remove that
by dressing people up like dolphins look
ike your daddy's a dolphin
yep you're the best looking devil i've
ever seen this is really weird oh my god
this is this is really weird right now
this has a weird experience for you
okay so are furries upset about this
show or are they really happy about this
show
there's a whole weird subgroup of people
who are attracted to people
in furry costumes and i don't know
whether this is like their ideal or
whether they're like
you're appropriating my culture man my
pet
is not your dating show my pet's culture
is not your dating show guys
i'll be honest i am curious as to
whether the
particular characters that are being put
on
these people in the dating profiles
actually have an impact like if you're
wearing like a super hideous costume
does that make it worse than if you're
wearing just a panda head like i feel
like if you're if you viscerally react
to the horrifying nature of some of
these masks does that have more of an
impact
or um i don't know i guess now i'm gonna
have to watch the show
please god no no cheers
uh oh look at this one oh no
i like your fin i like your fin okay um
so as david burge put it iowa hawk blog
over on
twitter you know in his day when we had
human dolphin abominations they at least
knew enough to cover their blowhole
what kind of a modesty is this just
putting your blowhole up there for
any straw man to see dude put that thing
away
they're like children here we'll get
some more in just one second first let
me just remind you
that you may think that what you're
doing online is private it isn't it used
to be
the private citizens wore private well
and the internet made all of that
obsolete
think about all the things that you've
browsed or searched for watched
tweeted now imagine all that data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
third parties into a permanent public
record
your record to keep my data private when
i go online i turn to my friends at
expressvpn
every time i turn expressvpn on my
connection gets re-routed through an
encrypted server i'm giving a random ip
address shared by other expressive vpn
customers
that makes it really difficult for third
parties to identify me and harvest my
data
and expressvpn is so easy to use like
let me show you
how this sucker works here on my phone
so here is my phone here is the app
expressvpn i bring it up
i hit this button right here doink now
i'm connected
look at that i'm protected it is indeed
that simple so
if like me you believe that your data is
your business secure yourself with the
number one rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com
get three extra months for free that's
exp our essvpn.com go to expressvpn.com
to learn more
so what if i pick you and i'm not what
you expect underneath
oh my god wait i'm noticing uh i'm
noticing something
every cutaway where they actually show
what some of the people look like these
are all very attractive people
i've yet to see somebody who's hideously
disfigured
right it turns out that pretty much the
guarantee is that if you wear the mask
the mask is just a mask and when you
take off the mask these people are not
going to be hideous what would make this
actually interesting is if you took off
the mask and it turned out to be like
phantom of the opera
[Music]
right where like you took off the mask
and half the it's like harvey dead
that would make this actually like
there's no risk factor here what if
everybody was really attractive and then
there was one person who was just
language unbelievably ugly but so far
every cutaway they have showed of one of
these people
shows that they are like at least an
eight out of ten so i feel like the the
downside risk for anybody competing is
that now
i hate this in re like when i made a
promise about what a show is to be
i want that promise fulfilled i remember
there was a show
way back when and it was titled joe
millionaire
one of the great reality show unkept
promises of all time
the entire premise of the show was that
there was a guy
he was a millionaire and women were
going to date him in order to
possibly marry him and he was a
millionaire and then the whole gag of
the show
is that joe was not in fact a
millionaire he was a plumber
and the whole hilarious aspect of the
show was going to see all these women
who were supposedly super into joe and
then it turns out he's just a shmo
and then they all just dump him because
it turns out they weren't into him they
were into his money
except that when they got to the final
episode yes i watched this entire show
i was like 17 or something i watched it
with my sisters it was hilarious
when we got to the end of the show they
had joe present
the girl he had chosen with like a 50
piece of jewelry so you completely
destroyed the incentive structure so of
course she showed up
didn't end up together of course don't
make this promise to me netflix
if your entire show is going to be about
how we have to find true love underneath
with fugly people then you have to make
some of the people fugly they can't all
be attractive but so far i've yet to see
an unattractive person
because netflix is having these cutaways
of the people without their masks on
i've kissed this girl and i don't know
what she looks like i'm literally just
like
in love with the moment in love with the
moment
okay so they're just dating wearing
weird masks
it's gonna be really tough for me i
can't choose both of you i've made my
decision
my sexy beast is
[Music]
oh there's inter-species relationships
happening
on my grounds i won't stand for
it oh it's all about intolerance that's
exciting
i'm i'm glad that we have reached this
point in life
teaching you know our citizens the
highest
of values ash first yep
things are going great here in america
probably we're going to be around in
like 50 years
probably for sure maybe not
if we are we're going to be some form of
inbred dr moreau
bizarre intraspecies product i know i'm
i'm i'm losing i'm losing hope
guys i'm losing hope i am dead inside
all righty
well i'm sorry that we had to watch that
together maybe we'll do better next time
leave us a comment
below hit a like hit a subscribe hit a
notification
so that way next time i'm tortured with
a video like this
you know about it first